et nous sommes avec patrick malvaes
président du syndicat national des
discothèques et lieux de loisirs
stéphane manigold restaurateurs porte
parole du mouvement restons ouverts
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
alors olivier véran l'a dit il ne serait
pas responsable de rouvrir les lieux
permet pas le moment de relâcher nos
efforts donc en clair pour vous ça veut
dire toujours pas de date de réouverture
vous désespérez sessad manigold plus les
jours passent plus les semaines passent
et plus elles se ressemblent et la sai
on entend à nouveau le même discours un
pas relâcher les efforts mais en
attendant on est fermée donc des efforts
le fait et on les fait au maximum et on
voit que le les hospitalisations sont
toujours là on a essayé de mettre en
place des protocoles sanitaires de
proposer des protocoles s'invite à
renforcer de façon à ce qu'on puisse
rouvrir pas de sujet je crois que
olivier ferrand est complètement fermée
à cette situation alors ne caricaturons
pas non plus tout gouvernement
il ya des personnes qui sont forcés à
bruno le maire il sans nos côtés on
essaie de leur faire des propositions
pour ouvrir notamment de terrasses comme
à new york
même s'il fait froid c'est un variable
qui est compliqué tout le monde n'a pas
des terrasses tous les restaurateurs
n'ont donc pas il ya encore des réglages
à faire sur le fond solidarité qui met
beaucoup de temps à arriver
voyez tous et tous ces points là pour
nous sont essentiels parce que c'est la
survie et c'est de pouvoir demain rester
ouverts restons ouverts restent ouverts
d'esprit restons ouverts dans le
dialogue se ressemblent et on voit pas
le bout du tunnel soyons clairs alors
patrick malvaes vous vous représentez
les discothèques alors là il a carrément
même pas un mot on a vraiment le
sentiment que ce seront les dernières à
ouvrir
comment vous prenez justement ce silence
c'est quelque chose que vous comprenez
ou au contraire nous imaginez vous que
c'est un manque de respect d'ici là
c'est absolument inquiétant le mot
discothèque c'est soit un gros mot soit
un mot qu'on élude pendant tous les cas
c'est pas très satisfaisant et c'est
très dommage
faire des efforts en ce qui concerne des
discothèques je vois pas ce que l'on
peut faire en plus les discothèques sont
fermées ça fait treize mois
c'est la première profession qui était
fermée de façon continue les divines
façon continue depuis 13 mois alors vous
imaginez que quand on voit qu'on oublie
un secteur qui souffre à ce point là qui
se trouvent dans cette position là c'est
parfaitement inacceptable qu'on ait été
oubliés on est oubliés au niveau des
discours officiels c'est vrai que c'est
pas toujours vendeur sauf peut-être
quand on veut en parler de mauvaise
façon
mais
sur le plan des aides matérielles nous
avons par le biais du fonds de
solidarité une assistance que je
qualifierais de minimal qui a été
améliorée ces derniers mois et nous
essayons de vivre avec ça c'était de l
élu d'un gros problème qui est le
problème la rémunération de l'exploitant
quand vous avez une exploitation
commerciale
c'est certes un moyen de faire de
l'argent et de collecter de la tva et
des taxes pour l'état de payer son
personnel
mais les dirigeants ne sont pas pris en
charge par le chômage et les dirigeants
se retrouvent sans salaire depuis 13
mois or ce sont les dirigeants de ces
établissements qui ont investi leur
propre argent qu'engagé dort bien quand
tout mis dans la balance pour créer leur
établissement et aujourd'hui c'est mon
père dit pour avoir perdu leur fonds de
commerce et en même temps ils n'ont pas
d'argent pour pouvoir continuer à payer
les dettes qui sont les leurs dons qui
vont devoir exécuter les garanties
qu'ils ont données soient leurs maisons
soient leurs biens personnels des eaux
ils ont perdu leur faut il espère
doubler le personnel
voilà où en est la situation au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est tout à fait critique
patrick malvaes vous parlez on reviendra
sur stéphane manning est évidemment
totale heures dont vous parlez de survie
est ce qu on a une idée du nombre de
discothèques qui ont fermé en france
parce qu'on imagine que la situation
comme vous dit doit être vraiment
critique pourquoi beaucoup d'entre elles
vous savez d'une gradation dans
l'horreur vous avez malheureusement
comme partout vous avez plus d'une
centaine d'établissements qui ont fait
un dépôt de bilan c'est à dire que les
tribunaux de commerce ont décidé de les
fermer
ces établissements sont fermés on n'en
parle plus ces 100 à 120 établissements
vous avez derrière une procédure qui
entre les deux concerts de sauvegarde et
procédés de règlement judiciaire
on a désigné un administrateur et là où
vous aussi vous avez 100 150
établissements qui sont là dans cette
situation un peu pénible pourquoi ils
sont venus dans cette situation c'est
parce qu'ils ont préféré se mettre en
situation de sauvegarde parce qu'ils ont
des bailleurs est propriétaire des murs
de leurs établissements qui continuent à
vouloir percevoir leurs loyers
commerciaux au même niveau que ce qui
l'était quand on fonctionne et donc
comme les états mission ne fonctionne
plus quand ils ont des loyers
commerciaux de vaincre
quarante mille euros c'est sûrement pas
pour donner uniquement aux bailleurs aux
propriétaires des murs qui se fait
beaucoup d'argent là-dessus avec un
fonds de commerce qui peut plus être
exploitée pour la destination pour
laquelle ils étaient loués et puis vous
avez une troisième donc il son procès de
sauvegarde ca moyen d'échapper à ce qui
est ainsi très particulier parce que le
gouvernement n'a pas pris là toutes les
mesures qu'il fallait envers les
bailleurs et il faut bien le dire comme
ça donc on se trouve obligé de se mettre
à ces procédures de sauvegarde où on se
trouve obligée d'aller devant les
tribunaux
actuellement on a déjà gagné quelques
instants ce très très importante et
facile devant les tribunaux c'est quand
même assez lamentable de voir aussi
c'est par ce front là et vous avez le
troisième niveau de gradation endroit ce
sont les gens qui eux mêmes prenant acte
de la situation que rien ne bouge et ont
décidé de fermer leur établissement
alors la plupart d'entre eux étaient des
très petits établissements au début de
la vie à peu près 120 130 autour de jean
mane à 150 parce que vous avez une
vingtaine d'établissements moyens aux
plus gros qui ont rejoint les autres et
qu'ils ont décidé de fermer c'est peu
même qui volontairement décidé de fermer
et vous trouver une issue au thé qui
sont en vente sur des sites sociaux
actuellement je voudrais vous faire
écouter vitoria colza en directrice de
recherche à l'inserm elle était
aujourd'hui aux côtés d'olivier verrons
lors de ce point hebdomadaire écoutait
ce qu'elle vit sur le couvre-feu ce
qu'on a pu voir c'est long c'est dans
ses analyses
ainsi non content de la présence ne va
rien britannique ce territoire en france
au début de l'année est issu des
estimations de la première enquête
flèche que ces cours un peu anticipée a
eu un impact considérable sur la sur les
reculs des la souche historique ici
j'appelle la souche historique que les
virus aux cov deux qui étaient en
circulation d'hellemmes dans l'année 20
ans avant l'arrivée des variances sur le
territoire français en gros si on avait
que c'est vrai ces sushis et la souche
historique on serait capable aujourd'hui
d'avoir un ré could et l'épidémie dans
les temps
grâce à ces couvre feu à 18h graphiques
à l'appui
stefan mani gueule quand vous voyez ces
graphiques et des explications de madame
polizia cétacés implacable ça vous
inquiète tout de même qu'est ce que
vous répondez soit le ministre houle en
tout cas le ministère de la santé ne va
pas assez loin dans la transparence des
explications et date dangerosité de la
co lead est ce qu'il y à il faut être
clair des débats profonds sur le fait
que l'on vive à côté non pas derrière ni
devant on à côté de ce virus et que l'on
vive normalement
soit ils ne disent pas réellement ce
qu'il en est c'est à dire que au fond il
ya une dangerosité bien plus importante
et raison pour laquelle on pénalise
globalement 99% de la population
française mais du reste je pas jeter la
pierre à la france dans le monde entier
c'est comme ça donc soit on ne dit pas
réellement quelles sont les conséquences
les troubles et les risques qu'il y a
lié à cette maladie ou la dp celle que
l'on voit et que l'on peut constater
qu'ici qu'on peut que déplorer ces
soixante quinze mille en france mais il
y a certainement des déjà un sens
neurologiques auquel on nous parle pas
et ça ça créé une fracture au fond avec
les français et les françaises sur cette
incompréhension ou alors tout simplement
on est on est dans le virus tel qu'on le
décrit et on comprend pas
fondamentalement pourquoi vous compris
vrai autant de personnes de fermer mais
restons deux secondes sur sur l'économie
on en parlait tout à l'heure les
bailleurs il ne joue absolument pas le
jeu ce sont les protégés de cette crise
sanitaire
pour la simple et bonne raison c'est
qu'ils n'ont absolument pas joué le jeu
lorsque le gouvernement met en place des
dispositifs notamment de réductions
d'impôts sur les traits des loyers qui
ont été proposées ils n'ont pas joué le
jeu et je ne vois pas pourquoi une
entreprise comme des discothèques comme
des théâtres comme des commerçants des
artisans des agriculteurs etc devraient
faire dès qu'on appelle prêts garantis
par l'état pour subvenir à des besoins
primaires de trésorerie et pourquoi ces
grands fonds ces bailleurs etc
eh bien il ferait pas comme nous ils
font appel à un prêt garanti par l'état
qui leur permettent bien de faire face à
leurs frais ils font des reports
bancaire comme nous avons fait jusqu'à
12 mois
ils font des rebords bancaire si l'on
sait on nous c'est tout le temps tout le
temps la pauvre petite mamie et c'est
déplorable et je peux comprendre qu'elle
a besoin
de cette pension pour vivre mais souvent
nous la gîte
mais moi je pense aussi à la mamie qui a
besoin de ça et qui a aujourd'hui un
local vide et qui demain ne retrouvera
pas un locataire lorsque vous parlez des
120 discothèque qui ont fermé je peux
vous dire que celui qui est le bailleur
derrière il est pas près de trouver un
locataire
donc je crois qu'à un moment les
bailleurs doivent faire des efforts
substantiels comme nous l'avons fait
maintenant depuis plus d'un an
notre outil de travail nos outils qui
nous permet de générer du du résultat
pour pouvoir les payer il est pas là et
rappelons tout de même que la cour
d'appel de paris s'est positionné le 9
décembre sur la force majeure on
indiquant que au fond les bailleurs à la
force majeure s applique c'est à dire
que les contrats se sont suspendus
vous voyez bien que il y a une espèce
encore deux de tension qui se rajoute au
stress à ce virus qui se propage au
manque de lisibilité
mes amis de la discothèque j'en parle
même pas je crois que le quand leur
slogan était de dire
la nuit doit voir le jour les pauvres
ils ont jamais été aussi aussi juste
dans leurs slogans mais aussi loin d'une
d'une réalité et quant à la profession
tous les non essentiels qui sont
aujourd'hui fermées n'est pas prêt de
voir le jour
mais quand nous dise clairement ce sera
juin ce sera septembre et au moins on
sera d'ap
mais là toutes les semaines écoutez le
ministre la santé pour nous a expliqué
que l'espagne vont être décisives mais
safed à 52 semaines avant qu'on nous
explique que les semaines vont être
décisives donc pourrions mon travail
quand même aller à des petits projets
notamment le qr code 1d mal à prononcer
tout à l'heure à cette année avant
d'entrer notamment dans des restaurants
stefan mani coque mais pourquoi pas
attendre à hier oui pourquoi pas aussi
des discothèques on va vous laisser le
mot de la fin mai mais rapidement tous
les deux ce bouquet pour vous laisser
parler l'un et l'autre c'est une bonne
idée on va dans le bon sens tout de même
patrick malvaes avec voilà ce genre
d'initiative de deux aspects du problème
le produit c'est l'aspect des libertés
publiques
qu'en est-il de cela je comprends quand
un exceptionnel il peut y avoir des
mesures exceptionnelles et qui payera
des entorses je rentrais pas dans ce
débat la deuxième chose c'est que le cou
ce code est parfaitement incompatible
avec ce qu'on appelle les protocoles
s'il ya des protocoles sont mis en place
on peut utiliser ou faire fonctionner
des établissements et des commerces
à condition qu'ils aient un ensemble de
mesures qui sont prises et dans ces
mesures le qr code entre pour une partie
mais il ya d'autres mesures
le problème qui apprend les discothèques
c'est que nenni les discothèques ne peut
pas fonctionner avec un protocole qui
prévoit une jauge réduite
nous sommes un modèle économique où on
travaille à flux tendus ou 6 et demain
nous dit vous devez avoir la moitié de
votre clientèle bas il vaut mieux qu'on
n'ouvre pas c'est tout à fait clair
parce que le la recette ne sera pas au
rendez vous on aura des charges plus
importantes et opérera plus d'argent que
d'être fermé donc fonctionné pour ne pas
pouvoir fonctionner dans des conditions
normales c'est impossible il ya une
deuxième chose qui est importante c'est
que la discothèque c'est très
particulier
vous y allez pour deux ou trois heures
et la fonction même de ce dieu c'est la
rencontre et les changes et le co vite
s'adresse précisément ça et si on dit
aux discothèques
vous ne pouvez plus dense et vous ne
pouvez plus rencontrer l'autre vous
devez avoir des masses etc
y a personne tu iras dans ces lieux là
donc c'est même pas la peine de mettre
en place un protocole donc le qr code
pour nous est une discussion tout à fait
secondaire parce que ça lui servir pour
certains commerces quand certaines
fonctions et où peut-être dans le cas
d'un ensemble global au niveau des
discothèques est hors de question
colorés ou en mode dégradé si vous
permettez l'expression
et ça n'a rien de péjoratif pour
bricoler les restaurateurs meiway
puisque ggg suis moi même mais
le fait que le client soit ne peut pas
être une solution pour ce qu'elle fait
de manuel très rapidement s'il vous
plaît ce qu'on arrive vraiment au bout
du débat vous êtes un petit peu long
tous les deux à chaque fois mais c'est
pas grave c'est intéressant mais mais
vite s'il vous plaît sur la conclusion
le qr code la bonne piste
le qr code est mal expliqué temps par le
gouvernement est mal compris par tout le
monde
le qr code c'est quoi lorsque nous
étions vert avec un protocole la
sanitaire anses ans et nous devions de
toute façon remplir ce qu'on appelait un
carnet où on enregistrait les noms des
personnes de façon à ce qu'on puisse
nous les alerter c'est un rôle
évidemment qui nous incombe à nous
n'avons pas de pouvoir de police et
encore moins pouvoir de santé et bien le
qr code permet en fait d'enlever ce
fameux carnets d'enregistrement des gens
qui venaient dans nos établissements
mais il le remplace simplement
donc on parle de liberté oui liberté oui
liberté pour tous évidemment mais on
peut pas considérer de façon collective
que la punition elle est collective ou
rien ça c'est pas possible
celles et ceux qui veulent pas
participer à ça malheureusement le
confinement il est là et puis on le voit
en autriche s'est on en train de
regarder le modèle autrichien puisqu'ils
ont appliqué ce espèces de 2 de
fonctionnement pour autant les
restaurants ne sont pas ouverts donc si
c'est pour nous mettre des règles ou au
fond les non essentiel en reste fermé ça
ne fonctionne pas si c'est pour qu'on
puisse les ouvrir et que les gens qui
sont non porteurs du virus puissent
pouvoir circuler et profiter de la
liberté et les autres se protéger ceux
qui sont atteintes de l'aco vide
évidemment qu'il faut être favorable il
faut pas être manichéen faut être précis
merci en tout cas tous les deux stéphane
manigold et patrick malvaes bon courage
à vous merci